la serie de mclaren para una función f
está dada por y bueno aquí tenemos a la
serie en notación signal y también
tenemos a la serie en notación expandida
y después dice esta serie convergen fx
para el valor absoluto de x menor que r
dónde r es el radio de convergencia de
la serie d mclovin inciso a usa el
criterio de la razón del radio de
convergencia para hallar a r primero si
estos términos de una serie de maclaurin
o de series que convergen o de pruebas
de radio son completamente extrañas para
ti o lo has olvidado y tiene recuerdos
confusos y borrosos de todo esto
entonces sería muy bueno que repasarán
estos conceptos en la canacar n
hay un montón de vídeos y de ejercicios
sobre cada uno de estos conceptos pero
si tienes una idea sobre esto vamos a
reforzarla recordando primero que es el
criterio de la razón
y bueno el criterio de la razón dice que
si tenemos una serie infinita si nos
tomamos una serie infinita desde n igual
a 1 hasta el infinito de un montón de
términos que les voy a poner a n
entonces el criterio de la razón nos
dice déjame escribirlo aquí el criterio
de la razón dice lo siguiente primero
que si consideras la razón entre dos
términos sucesivos es decir la razón
entre a en más uno
esto dividido a su vez entre a n y
después nos fijamos en el valor absoluto
de este radio nos fijamos en el valor
absoluto de este radio bueno esto por sí
solo no va a ser una constante como
vemos en las series geométricas de hecho
esto de aquí va a ser una función de n y
lo que queremos ver es el comportamiento
de esta razón cuando n es más y más y
más grande porque ya sabes si estamos
sumando todos estos términos por lo
tanto nos estamos acercando a infinito
entonces queremos encontrar el límite de
esto me voy a tomar el límite
límite cuando n tiende a infinito de
esto que tengo aquí esto es justo lo que
nos dice el criterio de la razón y si
este límite existe y es igual a l
supongamos entonces si él en dejan
escribirlo así si l es menor que 1 eso
quiere decir que la serie converge
déjame ponerlo así si él es menor que 1
entonces entonces la serie convergen
serie convergen y bueno si está l es
mayor que 1 entonces la serie divergen y
si él es igual a 1 podemos decir que
esto es inconcluso entonces lo que
queremos hacer aquí es encontrar de esta
serie que tengo aquí primero la razón de
esta serie y después nos vamos a tomar
el valor absoluto y una vez que ya lo
hicimos vamos a tomarnos el límite
cuando n tiende a infinito para ver para
qué valores de x este límite es menor
que 1
así que manos a la obra primero pensemos
qué es lo que va a pasar con el
subíndice n
uno está dividido a su vez entre a
subíndice n y lo que queremos ver es
cuánto vale esta razón entonces a
subíndice n 1 es lo mismo que sustituir
el valor de n por n 1 en esta expresión
y me quedaría lo siguiente me va a
quedar menos 3 esto elevado a lahm y
aquí en lugar de n voy a poner n 1 n más
uno menos uno bueno esto lo mismo que n
entonces voy a poner simplemente n por
equis elevado a la enee más uno muy bien
esto dividido a su vez entre n 1 entre n
1 y todo esto lo vamos a dividir entre a
subíndice n iv a subíndice n eso es lo
que tenemos aquí
3 elevado a la n 1 que multiplica a x
elevado a la n todo esto dividido entre
n muy bien ahora esta división de aquí
bueno esto va a ser igual a tener esto
entre esto es lo mismo que multiplicar a
esto por el recíproco de lo que tenemos
abajo entonces me quedaría menos 3
elevado a la n por x elevado a la n-1
está dividido entre n más uno y esto a
su vez que multiplica al cíclico de este
es decir n entre entre menos tres
elevado a la potencia en el -1 y esto
que multiplica
elevado a la n muy bien y ahora vamos a
simplificar esto lo primero que se me
ocurre es que podemos dividir el
numerador y el denominador por equis
elevado a la n iv entonces acá abajo me
va a quedar x a la n entre x l n lo cual
es lo mismo que uno ya que arriba me va
a quedar x al n 1 entre x l n lo cual es
simplemente x muy bien esto que
multiplica y ahora voy a dividir tanto
el numerador como el denominador por
menos 3 elevado a la n 1 entonces esto
de aquí me va a quedar simplemente 1 y
aquí me va a quedar menos 3 elevado a la
n entre menos 3 elevado a la n 1 bueno
pues eso es lo mismo que menos 3
muy bien y entonces todo esto me va a
quedar igual a menos 3 que multiplica a
x que a su vez multiplica a n todo esto
dividido entre n más uno muy bien y
ahora lo que queremos y ahora lo que
queremos es tomarnos el límite cuando n
tiende a infinito del valor absoluto de
esta expresión que tengo aquí es decir
queremos fijarnos déjeme bajar un poco
la pantalla y entonces nos vamos a
aplicar en el límite
cuando n tiende a infinito cuando n
tiende a infinito de bueno el valor
absoluto de menos 3x n está dividido a
su vez entre en más
muy bien y ahora seguramente reconoces
algo en este límite porque puedes ver
que tenemos el mismo grado tanto arriba
como abajo
ambos son n elevado a la primera
potencia entonces esto de aquí lo
podemos escribir de la siguiente manera
como el límite cuando n tiende a
infinito de bueno el valor absoluto de
menos 3x pero bueno esto lo podemos ver
de la siguiente manera esto lo podemos
ver como 3 que multiplican al valor
absoluto de x porque el valor absoluto
de menos 3 estrés y stones que
multiplica al valor absoluto de n entre
n 1 entre n más 1 y estoy seguro que ya
puedes ver que este límite tiende a 1 y
si no lo podemos ver más claro así esto
es lo mismo que él
límite cuando n tiende a infinito de
bueno 3 que multiplica al valor absoluto
de x esto que multiplica al valor
absoluto de y qué pasa si divido el
numerador y el denominador entre n en
esta expresión voy a simplificar un poco
me quedaría uno estoy dividido entre
bueno aquí me queda en entrene lo cual
es uno más uno entre n lo cual es uno
entre n y ahora sí puedes ver que esto
de aquí va a atender a uno cuando n
tiende a infinito porque uno sobre n
esto va a tender a cero entonces todo
esto de aquí tiende a 1 me va a quedar
simplemente que es igual a 3 que
multiplica al valor absoluto de
esto es lo que vale este límite de aquí
por lo tanto esta serie va a converger
si esto de aquí es menor que 1 déjame
notarlo la serie convergen
sí
si 3 que multiplica al valor absoluto de
x
esto es menor que 1 o bueno de aquí
podemos decir que el valor absoluto de x
tiene que ser menor a 1
tercio y ya está porque entonces hemos
encontrado que el radio de convergencia
r que nosotros buscábamos es lo mismo
que un tercio eso quiere decir que esta
serie de mclaren va a converger si el
valor absoluto de x es menor que un
tercio o podemos decir que el radio de
convergencia es igual a un tercio y ya
con esto acabamos el primer inciso